welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this section we're going to take a
journey through our solar system and
beyond
1977 marks the first fly of the voyager
program voyager is an mit-led program
with the original mission to study
planetary systems
now voyager 1 and voyager 2 to
spacecrafts are studying the
interstellar space
those two probes are still sending back
now more than 40 years later
information about you know measurements
of their surroundings back to earth
those are the two you know furthest away
objects were able to sort
but we have we are in age 20 and it's
irp so we are a little bit more
ambitious
our mission is to bring us to alpha
centauri alpha centauri is the closest
star and planetary system to our solar
system
it's actually not just one star but
multiple stars
and our journey brings us to proxima b
which is a planet
in the alpha centauri system
so we have a very fancy spacecraft it's
able to travel with the constant
velocity of
0.943
c speed of light
the gamma factor is 3 and the path which
is
which we're going to take
is five light years long
alice
is um
our ground control she is going to stay
on earth and bob is going to take this
journey
with virgin galactic
after some time bob is going to arrive
on proxima b
so your first charge
is to now
calculate how long does this trip take
from analysis alice's and bob's
perspective
so i asked you to stop the video here
and just works us out
so for alice the time needed
is 5 light years divided by 0.9 by the
velocity of 0.943 times the speed of
light and that gives us 5.3 years
so after 5.3 years
ali is observing bob's arrival on
proxima b
for bob the length of this path is
lauren's
lawrence contracted
um five light years divided by three
which is the gamma factor which results
to
1.67 light years
so for him the journey takes
only 1.77 years 1.67 light years divided
by 0.943
times the speed of light
so apparently
the time experienced by alice and bob
for the very same journey is different
so this now is the first part where we
enter
discussions of
paradoxes in special relativity and this
will bring us ultimately to an
understanding of the twin paradox
later in this course
you